i've been reluctant to talk about this
publicly and to my fans i have this
neuropathy a neurological disease it's a
genetic that i inherited from my daddy
it's called cmt ironically enough
because cmt was a big big part of my
career speaking out for the first time
on the today show alan jackson reveals
he was diagnosed 10 years ago with a
degenerative nerve condition called
charcot marie tooth disease as the
country music superstar explains the
condition affects his ability to walk
and has become more obvious through the
years as he takes the stage
there's no cure for it but it's been
affecting me for years and it's getting
more and more obvious and i know i'm
stumbling around on stage and now
i'm having a little trouble balancing
even in front of the microphone and so i
just feel very uncomfortable it's not
going to kill me it's not deadly but it
is related like muscular dystrophy and
parkinson's disease
[Music]
performing for fans over the past three
decades alan explains that sharing his
diagnosis feels like a huge relief in
some ways it's a relief because i was
starting to get so self-conscious up
there you know about
stumbling around so it i think it'll be
good for me now to get it out and open
and so if anybody's curious why i don't
walk right that's why and when it comes
to his plans of continuing to perform
the star says that the show must go on i
never want to do the big retirement tour
like people do and then take a year off
and then come back you know i think it's
kind of cheesy man i'm not saying i'll i
won't be able to tour i'll try to try to
do as much as i can so
if i'm coming to your town
welcome since they committed
[Music]
you